YouTube
で仏教についての質問とかアンチコメントがたくさん来てたので、今日は改めて仏教についてそこの説明をよろしくお願いします。
はい。はい。
色々批判とか質問とかいいたんだけど呼んでみると仏教が理解してないんやないかな。まずね、理解しようと思ったら仏教というのは何なのか。仏教の目的は何なのか。
それをどうやって解決すんのかという、
そいつが分からんといかんよね。仏教の
1番の問題はシハックなんや。だから
そいつが正しく理解できないと。
お釈迦様が仏教を開くまでの歴史を辿どっ
てみたらえっと彼は王族の子供やね。王族
の生まれやから金には困らん。権力もある
。本人は修でスポーツ万やったんで嫁さん
は綺麗でA嫁さんやったんで子供は渋さ
やったんやで普通考えると区が発生する
わけないじゃん全て満足されとるんところ
がそれでも苦が残るとなんでだろうという
ことやそれをその苦をなくすために修行に
入ったわけだから家を捨てて当時の
ウパニシャド哲学のやり方やからね家を
捨てて自分の身分も全て捨てて森に入って
いわゆる苦業というの7年やったかな
なんかやったんや。なぜそういうことを
するかと言うと精神はええんだけど肉体が
いかんのだっていうわけよ。哲学やからね
。だったらその肉体を死ぬ方に持っていっ
て死ぬ寸前まで持ってってみいとそうし
たら食がなくなるはずや。これが
ウパニシャ哲学なや。これが苦業なんやね
。食うものも食わずにひでえ環境の中で雨
が降ったら乗れるとかそういう森の中でね
ずっと修行を7年間続けたけど食は
なくならんやって
こっからが科学者の言えやこれは間違っと
んだとウパニシャ哲学は間違っとるんで
あるだから自分なりにもう1ぺやり直そう
として森から出てきて二川という川で体を
笑って横に生えとった母大樹の木の下で
休んどって、そしたらそこにスジャータと
いう女の子がやってきて、牛乳で作った
おかゆだ。そいつを食わしてくれた。
そいつで健康を回復して、体力を回復して
それから瞑想に入った。で、瞑想に入って
1週間かそこらで悟りを開いたい。そう
いうことやもんでお釈迦様が悟ったのは区
には2種類ある。1つはいい区と悪い区や
。
区というのはその区で行動する。行動し
たら結果が出る。結果が出たら区が消える
。で、会感が湧いてくる。これが幸福と
いうことなん。だから幸福の前には必ず区
がないといかんのや。で、今の教育論では
その人が取ってくれるわけよ。子供に発さ
せんようにしよう。何しろクは悪だから。
だけお釈迦様はク言る
わけ。ここ結構質問とかアンチコメで
多かったですよね。うん。だって苦があっ
て最後幸福になるんやから何のためにある
の?本能として行動させるためにあるんや
ないか。これは世界中が言っとるやん。
会議を求め不快を避ける。これがあの行動
の原理である。誰が考えてもそうなんやと
いうことは区がないと行動しないという
ことやったら幸福にもなれない。区
はいと悪い
があるっていう方悪い方の区についても
伺っていいですか?はい。
悪くをお釈迦様はシハックとしてまとめたわけや。だけど考えてみるとシ足して
12またはあれ八星
つの区があるぞと言っとる。白製と呼んどるんよね。
白星はどういう関係?
つの区白。その白の方を取ってハックせって言っとるんやだけどもあれも解釈間違っとるからね。シハックの妙な解釈をするもんでわけわからんようになるんや。あれはね悪い区が
つと言っとるわけやないんよ。思、ここが問題ない。小老病子や。水老病子って書くやろ。
はい。
あいつをもうな何ともな情は苦である。
おいることは苦である。病気になることは苦である。死ぬことは苦であるなんてそういう解釈しかできんところがダメなとこない。
僕も学校でそういました。
そうやろ。だからそうじゃなしに小区がしずる。これは悪い方の区がしずる。そうするとそれで行動してもことが解決しない。解決しなけりゃ区は消えない。だから繰り返し繰り返しやってもダめ。これ区が彷徨っとるやろ。だから寒さらない。
リで転内でローそれが深く大きくなって
いくんや。まだダめだ、まだダめだという
ことでこれがローで時にはそいつが病的に
なる神経症になったりしちしまうこれが病
で死というのはね固定するという意味ない
。変化しないだからもう苦が残ったままに
なる。これ具体的にはどういう状況ですか
?だから死ぬ前とする死ぬのは嫌だ。だ
けど必ず死ぬやろ。
だから死ぬのは嫌だをいくらなんとか死なないようにしようとしてもそれは無理ないんだから死ぬのは嫌だとずっと思ってるとあれになっちゃうわけ。しくハックになっちまうわけ。
個質問いいですか?このいい区と悪い区の定義っていうのが行動につがって
ちゃんと良くなるのがいいっていう風におっしゃってたと思うんですけど。
そうそうそうそう。
こ、具体的にこう例えばどんな例がありますか?
例えばね、嫉妬あれは怒りの変形やね。嫉妬というのは不会感はね、
3つしかないんよ。恐怖、強、怒り、この
つしかないんや。で、あと嫉妬は怒りの変形なんや。
恐怖、教学怒りっていうのはそれぞれ軽く解説いたいてもいいですか?
恐怖分かるやろ。逃げるのが恐怖。
はい。
怒りは立ち向かっていくのが怒り。驚愕というのは行動の変更を促しとるわけじゃん。
そのまだいかんぞっていうのが驚愕やろ。
だけど驚愕の足ん人は驚愕が来ると固定
しうんや。子供なんかそうやろ。びっくり
させると固まっちまうやろ。だから驚愕に
なれんといかんねん。そのためには
いろんなどんどんどんどん行動していくと
驚愕になれるんや。新しいことが来たら
すぐが起こるんやから自分の能力を起こす
ことが来たらまず教が起こるんや。
の怒りから発生したるのが嫉妬っていう感情
で例えばね学校で試験を受けると自分のライバルが必ずおるわけやろ。上のは上のように下は下のように。で、そのライバルが数学の試験をやったら
95点やったと。で、自分は
点やったと。奴のが上。それを知た時に嫉妬が起こるやろ。そういう自分の方がメだと分かった時に嫉妬が起こるんや。怒りだから。
その嫉妬を利用してもう勉強するわけよ。
数学の。で、次の試験の時に自分が95点
、やが90点やったら目的達成やろ。奴
より上に行きたいから嫉妬が起こる。幸せ
を感じるわけよ。相手をやつけてね。これ
が嫉妬の正しい使い方だ。で、こういう風
に嫉妬を使えば空内目的に合わせて使う
ところがも勉強はめんどくさいじゃん。
もう勉強しとる間にゲームができないわ、
テレビは見れないわで、もう勉強するの嫌
なんやね。でも嫉ッ妬は消したいやろ。
そうするとね、1人では無理やもんで仲間
を募ってな、そいつをみんなで踏ん付け
ちまうわけよ。自分たちより下にするんや
。奴より自分が上になったんだから嫉妬が
消えるはずなのに消えないやろ。数学で
嫉妬を起こしたんだから他のことではダメ
なんだ。だから目的が違っとるわけ。数学
を上達させようというのが嫉妬の目目的
やったのに。その怒り立ち向かうという
怒りやったのにそいつを数学以外のことで
やり上に行く。それも自分1人の
力じゃなくてみんなの力でね。ま、いじめ
やね。こんなことやったって目的は達成
できんからいつまでも嫉妬が残るやん。
これは怒りによる行動で集団でその
ライバルをいじめることうん。
あれはね、ライバルをいじめるのは逃げだ。恐怖の方なんや。だからそいつはシハックになるわけ。
なるほど
ね。間違った不快感の使い方やからね。これがシクハックなんや。だから
目的を間違えたらそういうことになっちまう。だからしないんようにというのはそんなことはありえないんだから目的を間違っとるんや。だからそんなもんで苦発生してもなしないんや。
だからお釈迦様のほどほどの人でも区が残るわけ。そういうことなんやね。
校長がよくおっしゃるその怒りによる行動は正しいっていう。そうそう。
これはちゃんと空の状態になってるから。
そうそう。立ち向かうからね。
え、1
点質問で、その区不快感から発生する行動が正しく使われてるのか、それともシハックの方になってしまってるのかっていうのは自分ではどうやって見分ければいいんですか?
それはね、自分の人間性を見たらええんだ。
結局強いということはええことなんだ。正しくってエネルギーもある。これが強いなんだ。普通強いのは悪い方に持ってくやろ。
だけど強いのは力を正しく使えるんだ。
乱暴力を間違って使う。これは弱いんだ。
だから強くならんといかんのよ。どうし
たら強くなるかが分からんといかんわな。
だけど強いのを嫌っても自分が弱いと思っ
て強くなりたくてもどうしたらそうなるか
をみんな知らんじゃん。そういう教育受け
てないから。から今のねリベラルでは無理
なんよ。そいつは解明してないからね。
仏教はちゃんと解明しとる。授況も解明し
とるんや。だからあれは科学ないよね。
だから仏教の目的はシハックから逃れる。
正しい区を発生させる。これが仏教の目的
なんや。で、シハ白の状態がリ廻転
行き詰まっとるんやね。だからそれから
逃れるためには空になればええんだ。で、
空になるためには修行修行の中でもみんな
座を組んだらええというのが今の仏教会
やろ。座を組んだってダめよ。座然の目的
はそういうことじゃないもんで。少年なん
よからな。少年で行動してみ。正しい行動
ができるから。ほんなもんね。自分で
いくらでも確かめれるんだ。だからどう
やったら少年になるかさえ分かればええ。
正しく念ずるね。だからその方法がある
わけよ。で、少年、常に少年で行動すれば
シックハックはもちろんなくなるし、
正しい行動ばっかりするから自分が進歩
する幸福になる。これが江戸時代の人なん
よね。で、今はリベラルの精神論が正しい
なんて、あのバカマスコミがね、わあ宣伝
するもんで、あんなものはアメリカに
押しつけられたもんやで。GHはヤ和魂が
怖かったんだ。
だから大和魂は悪いんだ、悪いんだということを朝新聞に命じて全国に報道させたわけやん
ね。大和魂の動画でもよくあった質問なんですけど、大和魂と仏教の関係について最後にお話しいただいてもいいですか?
そうやね。だから少年で行動する。これが大和魂なんや。だから少年ができたら大和魂を得たのと一緒のことない。
だからどうしたら少年になるかを一生懸命
考えてみ。簡単なことや。で、しかもね、
すぐ実証できるんよ。自分でやってみたら
、あ、なるほどと思う。仏教のがなぜ科学
かと言うとね、お釈迦様の言葉でね、こう
いうのがあるんや。私が言うから信じなく
てもよろしい。仏教の権者やね。偉い坊さ
が言うから信じなくてもええ。自分でやっ
てみ。その通りになるからって言っとるに
。
これが今俺の言った少年でやったらちゃんとできるよというのと一緒なんよね。そいつをなんかわけのわからんもんにしちまったのが大丈仏教やろ。
少年でまず自分でやってみるっていうのは具体的には何からやってみるのが良さそうとかありますか?
全ての行動少年でやってみ。そうすると自分の苦手だったはずのものがちゃんとできることが分かる。
最初のヒントとしては日常生活のあらゆる動作とかで少年を意識してみることからっていう
少年で何でもええよ。例えば物を運ぶ時でも俺がよく言うのはコップに水をかなり上まで入れてなそいつを運んでみとこぼすやろ。それを少年で運んでみこぼれんからどうしたらいえかん。
少年でやるっていうのは具体的にはもうちょっとだけ少年の状態のヒントいただいてもいいですか?
うん。精神的状態が問題なんよ。だから精神で恐怖が出らんようにすりゃええんやな。怒りで構造すれば正しい行動になる。だからどうしたら恐怖が出ないか。さらに精神の定義は行動のプログラムやろ。
はい。
正しいのは本能じゃん。だったら理性を殺して本能で行動してみ。
ちゃんとできるから理性は正しいけど本の
は間違っとるというのがヨーロッパの精神
論やろ。だけどなぜ正しいかは言ってない
やろ。で日本がそれを真似したんだけど
当然のことなぜ理性が正しくて本能が
間違るかななんてのは全然言ってない
じゃん。習ってないもんね。だけど仏教は
そう言る。受教もそう言っとるんだ。本能
が正しいから本能的な行動すりゃ間違いは
ないんや。
大和魂も科学であって本能論っていうことですか?
本能論だよ。だから大和魂でずっと行動してる間にそれが理性になるんや。そういうことやろ。正しい行動したらそいつが理性になる。仏教もそう言っとるやろ。法が残る因が王法あるいは因が合法。
原因により蚊かが生ずる因のないものは
生じないだから飛べって飛べんやないか
その飛ぶあれがないやないか因が要素が
人間には備わってないから合法は豪行動や
行動により法が残る法というのは理性の
ことねだから正しい正しい行動により
正しい理性ができるという意味なんだ。
だから今みたいに偏差修のいかんのは行動
してない。覚えとるだけなんや。使えん
やろ。だからもしあそれを知ったらそれが
できるんだと言うんならウンドサーフィン
の乗り方を教えてるから乗ってみや。絶対
乗れへんのや。あれを最初から乗った人
なんておらんのや。散々苦労して失敗して
その後でできるものなんや。これが進歩の
法則やねんけ。だから行動せずに知ったと
いう地方が多い一やからね。知ったという
ことはできるということやから。だから
行動もしてないのに知ってるって言っては
いかんのだ。これはイチない。だから
テレビのコメンテーターにしろ、
アナウンサーにしろ教育論がどうのこの
お前の教育論が間違っとると言うやん。
お前やったのかということやりもせんのに
分かったつもりになるなということ。だ
からテレビの言うことはみんな嘘やと思っ
たらええんや。何にもやってないんやから
。で、しょうがないもんで日の人を連れて
きて教育の説明をするやろ。あれら、失敗
した奴らやん。成功戦とダめだよ。知識に
なってない。知識の式というごべに音を
書いてほやな。知識とのの式ということは
ソフトウェアという意味なんよ。地の
ソフトウェア理性だ。だからこいつは行動
しないとできないよ。か全て行動が大事で
非常にありがたいのは精神というのは行動
のプログラムだけど正しい精神が正しい
行動を行わせるだけどありがたいことに逆
も真なりないよ。正しい行動をすると
正しい精神ができる。だから少年でやれと
いうことて正しい理性ができるぞ。
そういうね、きちっとこうメカニズム的にしっかりしてるのが授況や仏教やないか。
仏教についてはまた他の内容もあると思うので動画はどんどん続けていきたいと思います。
はい。批判してくるのはええけども
つは今の地候が一自分はちゃんとそれができたという宿泊じゃない。
あの、リン廻転が生まれ変わり人間から
ネズミになり、ネズミから昆虫になり、
昆虫からまた人間になったとかそういう風
だと言うんならどうやってそれを証明した
んや。お前がずっとその前世の記憶から
あるのか。だ、あんた前世は何やったの?
ネズミだったのかだったのか。それが
分かっとるのか。自分の経験としてね。
だったら言ってこいよと。だけどああいう
ウパニシャド哲学のようなものを信用して
お釈迦様はウパニシャド哲学は間違っとる
ということでウパニシャ哲学を正しくした
んだ。だから仏教というのはウパニシャ
哲学のお釈迦様というのはウパニシャド
哲学の中高の層だと思ったらええんや。
ウパニシャと哲学で言われとるいろんな
言葉を解釈を変えとるわなみんなからリ廻
転職も解釈を変えとるんだ。で転職という
感じを信用せずにその前のサムサーラと
いうことをしっかり考えんといかんのや。
あれは中国人が勝手に訳したものやからね
。だからそのリン廻転職という言葉に釣ら
れてみんな生まれ変わることやと思っとる
。誰かが最初に昔の人が間違えたんやな。
リ廻転職はこうなんだ。よう考えようよ。
で天章を生まれ変わりだという人は仏教の
目的が分からんやろから仏教の目的はリ廻
転章から逃れること解決することなことを
ねこれね逆に言うとリン廻転章がはっきり
分かっとると教育改革はできるよ改革今
行き詰まっとるやろ行き詰まっとるのを
正しくすりゃ解決するじゃんならお釈迦様
の言う通り仏教を使ってやりゃええでしょ
だからそれができるという人やったら話
聞こうや
じゃないか。だけどそんなことできんのやろ。みんなできるんやったらもうやっとるわな。俺がやる言ってやったらええんやけどね。じゃ、我こそはという地候強合一でしっかり骨のある反論を送ってくださる方はコメント欄などでお待ちしております。
うん。科学的にやっとくれ。宗教はいかん。宗教というのはな、絶対不いものがいるんだ。神様がいる必要ないんや。ところが仏教は最初に神様否定しとるやないか。
商業無上って言うんや。全てが変化する。全てが変化するということは神がいないということやで。その仏教を宗教として扱ってはいかんのや。科学ない。
ありがとうございます。
はい。
とかヨットスクールを支援する会のやでございますが、セミナーのはと塚よ支援する会のメールアドレスまでよろしくお願いいたします。
それと校長の動画に関する質問並びに反論は戸塚@スクールの支援する会のアドレスまでお願いいたします。
ありがとうございます。タッフからも令和スクールというのは支援する回答とはまた別の団体なので、あのコメント欄を楽しんでいただくのは大丈夫なんですけど、校調にちゃんと聞いて欲しいこととかはなるべくメールの方にお願いします。ありがとうございました。